du fromage des légumes de la charcuterie
ou des pâtes fraîches les richesses du
marché notre dame de versailles des
produits inspirant pour les spécialistes
de la cuisine comme les parrains de la
fête internationale des marchés 2018
on identifie ce que l'on va mettre à
l'intérieur son corps sur un marché
c'est à dire que on ne mange pas de
manière anonyme
en mettant au four un plat pré pré pré
pré pré préparé et qui traverse toutes
les saisons on est là en train de suivre
le pouls on prend le pouls d'une saison
c'est un beau marché parce que je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup des producteurs
directs et ça c'est très important je
suis roman pour le kilomètre zéro
consommer vraiment un régional et
j'allais être des saisons les
commerçants et producteurs partage
d'histoire des produits manière de
cuisiner au dû préserver la limande des
conseils donnés aux clients et on adore
le faire parce qu'elle est la
convivialité
on aime faire plaisir aux gens c'est un
vrai partage on les voit heureux à
travers les produits qu'on leur vend
donc tout ça ça nous rend heureux mais
écoutez je pense que c'est vraiment un
très beau marché et tous les personnes
qui viennent ici sont immédiatement
conquis d'abord il est beau visuellement
et surtout il est beau et bon parce que
les produits sont de qualité près de 105
marché francilien participent à la fête
internationale des marchés
une opération prévue du 11 au 27 mai